hace 7 años mucha llegó a israel huyendo
de la violencia en sudán en su travesía
de 16 días por el desierto del sinaí dos
de sus compañeros fueron asesinados al
cruzar la frontera las autoridades
israelíes lo encarcelaron seis meses en
sarón ym y un año en el centro de
detención a cielo abierto dejó lot antes
de ser liberado sin saber hebreo ni
tener permiso para trabajar o estudiar
no es que nos trataran de mala manera
pero fue muy difícil lidiar mentalmente
con la incertidumbre de no saber si te
van a enviar de vuelta a tu país o si te
van a dejar entrar desconfían de ti
entonces toda la ayuda que pides y
necesita recibir no te la dan
es la realidad de más de 30.000
solicitantes de asilo en israel la
mayoría de sudaneses eritreos que sufren
un limbo legal solo desde hace semanas y
mucha pertenece al menos del 1% que ha
recibido el estatus de refugiado en su
integración el fútbol y un equipo fueron
claves estudiantes
nacida hace cinco años en la filial
israelí del club argentino estudiantes
de la plata mucho de un grupo de amigos
a un equipo multicultural que junto a
dos ongs asiste y reúne todo tipo de
ayuda a refugiados
nosotros hecho combatimos las barreras
de los estigmas y los refugiados buenos
se encuentran con problemáticas como por
ejemplo no tienen un seguro social no
tienen una posibilidad de estudiar en
cualquier lugar como si podría por
ejemplo un inmigrante o un israelí
estamos ahí en todo eso para ayudarlos a
que salgan adelante bajo las órdenes del
entrenador de este conjunto de israelíes
inmigrantes latinoamericanos y
solicitantes de asilo de áfrica se
entrena cada jueves para competir en una
liga amateur una vez que te pones acá en
el césped entras a jugar no importa si
hablas un idioma otro idioma en el
fútbol es como que su lenguaje aparte
se rompe esa barrera adentro de la
cancha se entiende por los otros
sectores es un lenguaje el espíritu de
la filial pasa de boca en boca y cada
vez más solicitantes de asilo buscan
seguir los pasos de musas que frente al
vacío institucional de israel encontró
un hogar dentro y fuera de la cancha